George George would you grow up where
you from originally I'm Los Angeles and
I'm was raised in East LA East LA and
you hit both your parents growing up
both my parents growing up and we lost
my mom when we were 19 I was turning
nine years old and I had an older
brother and a younger brother I'm the
middle child my brother passed away two
gang violence
my older brother rest in peace and uh
then I took over you know I was I had to
be the older brother and the father
figure sort of because my dad end up
walking away so yeah my grandma I stayed
we stayed with my grandmother until I
turned 16 and then I started working and
it's been on since then and you know I
know can you you have a family yeah I
have kids I got five five girls and one
boy and they for the grace of God I
think they grow up really really good
kids that's great with kids and how many
years even married going on thirty
thirty years even married calling Donna
30 M strong 30 that's great and what
would you do for a living I work
construction and I rebuild homes right
now I'm doing commercial work or
renovating buildings here and you know
downtown okay
you come down down here to skid row and
pick up some of the friends that I've
interviewed before so the ladies exactly
exactly I come down here because uh
obviously it's it's it's it's it's a
known fact that as you get older you get
dysfunctional but uh luckily for me I
did it because I do a lot of exercises
as much as testerone it was really high
so I need to come down here and get rid
of some energy
what how often are you going down here
I'm coming down here every day every day
you sund'ys you'll pick up somebody
every day pretty every day I pick up
someone really yeah Wow and how many
years you've been doing that going on
like probably seven eight years now
well yeah there are there certain ladies
that you hit more often than I yeah I
there's so there's a couple girls that I
that I usually come and pick up twice
maybe three times a week and
they become my regular ones and Vicki's
been a great deal of help to me yeah
yeah Vicky's who brought you in I think
he's the one that brought me in for me
so what the relationships you have with
these girls how do you how do you so
you're married yeah and you've been
married a long time yeah and she knows
and she knows she has to know I can't do
this without her not knowing right yeah
I eventually get the truth always comes
out
always always and uh I don't want to
lose my marriage to this I mean but uh
she understands what what what's going
on you know and I'm protecting I use
safe sex I don't you know the
intercourse is very very very unlikely
most of the time you know it's just all
sex and a lot of talking and I try to
help these girls out a little bit you
know I just don't want to forget where I
came from you know yeah good for you and
so so where will you take them you'll go
to your car or you go rent a room I
haven't regular room that I rent and
they rent them by the hours but I go
ahead and ran them by a couple of days
so that the girls have a couple of days
to stage somewhere in oh so you give
them a place you know it's it's only
fair that that if they're providing
service for me that I'd provide
something for that that's nice yeah
because I hear so many stories from the
girls that yeah guys beat them up they
ran out baby yeah I don't yeah you know
I have a good time with them to actually
you know because there's their job
they're really down-to-earth girls they
don't you know they they do what they do
because it's something that they have to
fall on because they have no education
they have no career behind them I have
nothing nothing so they use their body
to make their money you know and
I mean if that's what it is and that's
what it is you know and I'm one of the
ones that happened to take that as a
service you know and I try to help him
out as much as I can you know and I put
them up in a room for a couple of days
and give them a few dollars so that they
can go get something to eat get
something you know something where so
they look good you know you look good
you feel good you know you act good you
make good money that's really nice of
you absolutely did you go into other
neighborhoods yeah I actually you know I
like tried Hollywood I tried the North
Hollywood
I tried is San Diego Valley I've been
just about everywhere in Los Angeles you
know I even went up to the mountains and
tried an experience up there with a
couple of girls up there and they were
up there camping and they were like
mountain girls I would say you know
they're doing business and we're doing
they were doing this and something
believe it or not you know and it was
really interesting real it was quite an
experience actually and we went to Lake
Havasu you know and we did we did we did
some things up there and and at the lake
well on on a plan to boat you know it
was we've had quite an experience you
know my wife is trying to get involved
but she's like being heck you know being
she's holding back on it because she's
embarrassed to say that she has a
problem you know and
and there's no reason for that for her
to be embarrassed about any of that you
know we've been married for so long that
we've accepted it and she's accepting
what I do and as long as I don't bring
anything to her and ID that I leave that
on the street when I come home you know
when I come home I'm the person that I'm
supposed to be it when I'm at home you
know and that's the husband and I take
care of her and I take care of my
finances and as long as there's a roof
over our head we have food to eat and
she's safe and healthy she's happy yeah
so yeah you describe her as a happy wife
yeah so very much so you know he's he's
got a good bank account have you have
you ever had problems with the police oh
yeah lots of times they think they know
me regularly down here in resident yeah
they I've been arrested several times
down here for for Celine Celine oh yeah
you know and I tell them I tell them the
truth you know and when I get to court
they throw it out you know the judges
already know me
you know they they they tell me that I
need to get myself back home and uh and
strain on my marriage what's your view
on prostitution do you do you see it as
like your you're not hurting anybody
the girls need money and they're making
money sure I'm sure there's a is that
your view on it no you know what look
let me tell you it prostitution is one
of the oldest profession there is okay
and this has been going on since before
you and I were here and it's gonna go on
and when we're gone you know and there's
no stopping it so a lot of us condoning
a lot of us don't you know but uh the
ones that do are the ones that actually
put put money into it and and it helps
them you know a lot of the girls are
broken homes just badly badly how
stricken I mean it just sit there
they're in bad shape
that's shape and they're looking for
somebody like us to just either pull
them out or become a regular there so
that they can keep doing what they're
doing on a signal you know because I've
had I've had
girls where they're completely beat up
they're you know they're scared you
can't touch them they just you know
they're they're there because they need
to eat you know and I understand that I
really understand them ya know I've
talked to a couple that got beaten up
recently really bad really bad yeah
really like like and kidnapped first few
days and stuff like that yeah well you
know they think that's some couple girls
that have guys that they say they take
care of them but they take their money
beat them up you know and and leave them
without nothing and it lowers our
self-esteem so low that that they depend
on these guys they depend on you know
and they take advantage you come down
here oh like day night we're out here
I'm down here during the day work and
then after them after after I get off
work I I'll go home take a shower get
dressed and come back out and then I'm
out for about 3-4 hours and then I go
back home yeah and so you hold you I'm
going on 5555 and you're you're doing
this every night I'm doing this every
night oh yeah acting yes you are you're
doing something right
you find the variety is what keeps it
interesting for you very much so very
much so you know I like all saw all
sexes you know I just mean you say all
sexes you mean all races all races all
races you know no no sir I like blacks I
like whites I like give you know that
inside that and more so down here in Los
Angeles you know you're gonna get girls
from all over the place you know I've
tried a couple of Russian girls and you
know I try to stay away from them
because they're more into low political
type of aspect of sex you know they they
they they're trying they're they're
trying to get into not street type of
sex they're they're they're more like
escort service type oh and I'm trying to
stay away from all that and they
probably it more expensive very much so
very much what's the most you've ever
paid for 150 150 what's the least you've
ever paid 20 20 20 dollars yeah and but
those are those are crack boards and I
try to stay away from those
I did do it for four so they can go
small you know and I don't do drugs so
I'd stay away from from that so you know
if that's what you're gonna do after I
give you money then that's on you you
know I need to do what you want to do
but when you're with me keep that away
from me yeah you know and and and stay
clean with me you know I and that means
a lot to me your hygiene means a lot to
me and if you like if you can't take
care of yourself then I really don't
want to see you you know and they make
it a point to make sure that they go and
buy something new to wear and they they
take care of themselves for a couple of
days and they don't let themselves go
you know and then the ones that do let
themselves go is because they're highly
strung out on drugs and I I try to stay
clear from that because I really not
trying to catch anything from anybody
take it home to my wife have you ever no
dude I've been very lucky
yeah I've been very lucky you know and
there's been a couple of times where I
don't practice safe sex and I thought
for sure I was gonna catch something and
I did you know I go to doctor regularly
I get shots with regularly I get checked
regularly for everything you know and
I've been clean I've been I've been very
lucky you know so I think it's gonna be
good till that happens this probably was
the day that I stopped yeah but for the
meantime I'm having a great time and I
know I'm blowing a lot of money but I'm
doing it in a way where I'm helping
somebody that's the way I'm looking at
it yeah all right George well thank you
so much for talking to me and I
pre-canned enjoy your your weekend thank
you as well perfect
you